ROB:  WELCOME BACK.
A FOX NEWS ALERT.
ONLY NINE STATES IN THE U.S.
WILL PEAK IN COVID-19 DEATHS BY
THE END OF APRIL.
THAT ACCORDING TO A NEW MODEL
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS.
CARLEY:  WHAT DOES THE SHOCKING
DATA MEAN AS THE COUNTRY TRIES
TO REOPEN?
HERE WITH HIS EXPERT INSIGHT,
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR,
DR. MARTY MAKARY.
DR. MAKARY.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT REOPENING
THE COUNTRY, BUT THIS MODEL
SHOWS A MAJORITY OF STATES ARE
GOING TO REALLY REACH THEIR PEAK
OVER THE SUMMER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
TIMELINE?
>> WELL, IT’S VERY INTERESTING,
CARLEY.
YOU KNOW, THIS MODEL FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS AT AUSTIN
LOOKED AT CELL PHONE DATA TO
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR
NOT PEOPLE WERE PRACTICING TRUE
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
AND USING THAT INFORMATION, THEY
TRIED TO CALCULATE WHEN THE PEAK
IS GOING TO BE COMING AROUND.
IT’S INTERESTING.
EVEN THOUGH THE COUNTRY ENGAGED
IN DIFFERENT OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT
POLICIES AT DIFFERENT TIMES, THE
PEAK HAS BEEN RELATIVELY
HARMONIOUS.
THAT IS, WE’VE NOT SEEN THE
STAGGERING OF PEAKS OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO MONTHS AS THE
MODELS HAVE PREDICTED.
WE’VE SEEN THINGS THAT AT LEAST
THE INCREASE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS, THE INCREASE
IN ICU STAYS AND THE INCREASE IN
DEATHS ARREST RELATIVELY AROUND
THE SAME TIME NATIONALLY.
AND SO IT’S INTERESTING TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THIS MODEL THAT
PREDICTS EARLY PEAKING IN SEVEN
DIFFERENT STATES TURNS OUT TO BE
TRUE OR NOT.
ROB:  AND IF THAT’S NOT
TROUBLING ENOUGH, WE ALSO HAVE
THIS CONCERN ABOUT IMMUNITY IN
PEOPLE THAT HAVE ALREADY HAD IT.
LET’S LISTEN TO DR. DEBORAH
BIRX.
>> WE KNOW THAT WHEN YOU GET
SICK AND YOU RECOVER AND YOU
DEVELOP ANTIBODIES, THAT THAT
ANTIBODY IS OFTEN CONFERS
IMMUNITY.
WE DON’T KNOW IF IT’S IMMUNITY
FOR A MONTH, SIX MONTHS OR SIX
YEARS.
ROB:  DOCTOR, IF YOU’RE IMMUNE,
IF YOU GET IT AND YOU’RE IMMUNE
FOR A COUPLE MONTHS, WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN?
>> WELL, IT COULD MEAN THEIR
SUSCEPTIBILITY IN THE FALL WHEN
WE EXPECT A SECOND WAVE.
I SAY THAT NOT TO EXPECT PANIC.
WHEN WE SEE CASES IN SEPTEMBER,
WE DON’T WANT TO CREATE
HYSTERIA.
THIS MAY BE EXPECTED.
IT MAY BE WE GET THIS MANAGEABLE
TO A POINT WHERE IT’S MORE LIKE
THE SEASONAL FLU.
THE ANTIBODIES, WE DON’T KNOW
WHAT THEY MEAN.
SO WE’VE GOT TO REMEMBER THAT
IMMUNITY JUST MEANS AT THE TIME
THAT YOU’RE TESTED.
CARLEY:  YOU KNOW, I THINK WHEN
PEOPLE HEAR THAT A MAJORITY OF
STATES ARE GOING TO PEAK
SOMETIME IN JUNE, THAT SCARES A
LOT OF FOLKS.
THEN WE ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THE FACT THAT WE ARE SORT OF
ALREADY SEEING A NATIONAL
FLATTENING OF THE CURVE AND A
LOT OF GOVERNORS ARE SAYING THAT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO EXPERIENCE
THE PEAK THAT THEY ANTICIPATED
IN THEIR STATES.
SO HOW DO YOU KIND OF SQUARE
THIS STUDY AWAY WITH WHAT WE’RE
ACTUALLY SEEING ON THE GROUND IN
INDIVIDUAL STATES?
>> WELL, REMEMBER, EARLY ON,
CARLEY, WE THOUGHT THAT A PEAK
MEANT A MASSIVE SPIKE AT ONE
MOMENT AND WHILE THAT WAS THE
CASE IN NEW YORK AND MAYBE IN
LOUISIANA, WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
AS PEOPLE GOT AWARE, AS THE WORD
GOT OUT, AS WE HEARD FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE EARLY ON ABOUT EVEN
THE INITIAL 15-DAY MEASURE, THAT
PEOPLE STARTED TO TAKE THE RIGHT
PRECAUTIONS.
THEY STARTED TO DO SOCIAL
DISTANCING, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THEIR GOVERNORS SAID AND WHAT
WE’VE SEEN IS MOST OF THE
COUNTRY HAS STARTED TO PLATEAU
AROUND THE SAME TIME WHICH IS
THIS WEEK.
THIS IS THE PEAK.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE WEEK AND
MAYBE THE FOLLOWING WEEK FROM
THIS WEEK THAT IS PROBABLY GOING
TO REPRESENT THE PEAK AND WHAT
WE’RE GOING TO SEE IS A
PLATEAUING WHERE, YES, THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF CASES
TECHNICALLY MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT DOWN THE ROAD BUT WE’RE
STARTING TO SEE THAT PLATEAU
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND OUR CONCERN IS HOW LONG IS
THAT GOING TO GO ON FOR AND CAN
WE GET LUCKY AND HAVE THIS VIRUS
MUTATE TO A SAFER FORM OR CAN WE
COME UP WITH A THERAPEUTIC IN
THE MEANTIME OR CAN THE
DISTANCING STOP THE TRANSMISSION
FROM PERSON TO PERSON SO THAT WE
REDUCE THE BURDEN IN SOCIETY TO
MAKE IT MANAGEABLE.
CARLEY:  THAT’S RIGHT.
YOU DON’T WANT THAT PLATEAU TO
LAST FOR -- YOU WANT TO SEE THAT
DIP.
DR. MA MAKARY, THANK YOU FOR
BREAKING THAT DOWN FOR US.